was your a point where you said [ __ ] it  man  I'm leaving stand-up comedy I would  think like I thought about retirement  forget stand-up I thought about suicide  man yeah oh I was that damage in the  hospital man I want to live I saw me if  you wasn't there you didn't think it was  very good  market ah I was struggle to say words  yeah I couldn't walk so when a wound on  my ankle in front of my left ankle man  that look like a horseshoe you could  pull my skin back and see my bone Tracy  what's the motivation to go out and do  stand-up it was my wife mostly I start  out real depressing I gain weight and  then after the settlement I was still  depressed I was still in that mindset  and I'm laying on the couch and then one  day she just said why don't you get up  and go to the comedy club you big gut  [ __ ] be nice that's good